a drive into the west bank
is a journey into a struggle that hasn't
changed for decades
donald trump says he's now brokered a
pathway to peace
maybe but how long before it runs
through the place where it really
matters
there's been a flurry of excitement from
israel to abu dhabi and beyond over the
deal and it is potentially
a game changer between the jewish state
and the arab world with trade deals
flights
tourism and peace they claim but what's
the reality
at the heart of the conflict they say
they'll solve
we're heading to the west bank
palestinian town of anabta
after an incident that happened a day
earlier
we found him in his back garden
left
had been among a group protesting a plan
by israel to build an eight square
kilometer industrial park
expanding its already illegal
settlements into more palestinian land
with his flag and his walking stick he
rejected the israeli soldier's demands
that he leave
there was a scuffle he pushed a
soldier's gun away
he's then pushed to the ground and
handcuffed
is
and he has spent time back in the 80s in
an israeli jail
he is for them a terrorist but for
palestinians he represents a daily
struggle
for land and equality
we drive deeper into the west bank
there's been a report of a car ramming
the israeli security forces control over
60
of it and they're quick to release cctv
of the incident
the car driven by a young palestinian
man drives into an israeli soldier and
police officer
he gets out preparing to attack them
with a knife we're told
he's shot and injured well this is a
typical flashpoint it's a junction in
the heart of the west bank it's
palestinian land
in their eyes but the israeli
settlements are all around over there on
the hill you can see
one of the settlements these are illegal
under international law but
they're allowed by the israeli
government and they continue to be built
and as we move around you can see
over here there is a bus stop this is an
israeli bus stop israeli soldiers
guarding it that's for the settlers to
be able to move from one settlement
within the west bank to another this is
just the sort of place
where incidents like this tend to happen
today there are more than three quarters
of a million israeli jewish settlers
living in the west bank
that's more than triple the number who
were here in 1993
when the oslo accords promised a piece
which never came
among them is raquel gordon from london
originally
when we moved here about 20 years ago
that arab town was very very small
and it's grown exponentially since we
moved it but do you not see a sort of
that you're being a bit hypocritical in
the sense that you're saying that the
arab town has grown
but but your town wasn't here at all
this is
as far as i'm concerned it's israeli
territory
and um the whole of
the whole of israel belongs to the
jewish people
for decades the palestinian quest has
been their own state
with east jerusalem as their capital and
with jewish settlers moving back out of
the west bank
but is that still achievable or should
israel's deal with gulf arabs prompt a
new palestinian strategy
i think what we have to do as
palestinians is recognize that there is
an apartheid one-state reality
except that as a starting point but not
accept it as our future
it really stresses the need for
recalibration of the palestinian
struggle
that we can't rely on people that we
thought were allies
that we have to sort of seek out
allyship friendship
um interconnectedness with with other
struggles with other peoples around the
world
there are hints of that already
parallels drawn between perceived
injustices here and elsewhere
palestinian lives matter is the slogan
our journey ends in ramallah a statue of
nelson mandela stands as a symbol
of equality and freedom it's an irony
that the young palestinian rapper at his
feet
told us he didn't know who the old man
was
you don't know him equality here
seems far off mark stone sky news
in the west bank